eine riesige blase umgibt unser
sonnensystem und nun haben forschende
spektakuläre entdeckung über diese
struktur gemacht die unter anderem etwas
mit der explosion uralter sterne unserer
milchstraße zu tun haben und erklären
weshalb wir uns im zentrum dieser blase
befinden klick substanz in future geht
es dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und activity
glocke nur so verpasst der nexus geht's
herzlich willkommen wir sind in gewisser
hinsicht ja eine galaktische rand
erscheinung unser sonnensystem ist
nämlich nur eines von mehreren hundert
milliarden sternen systemen innerhalb
der milchstraße von unserer randposition
aus ist es gar nicht so einfach
erkenntnisse über den rest der galaxis
zu gewinnen doch forschende sind durch
unglaubliche daten des weltraumteleskops
trotzdem auf die schliche einer
kosmischen struktur bekommen die uns
umgibt alles dazu wird euch nun team vom
kanal aus totem erzählen bei dem ihr
übrigens unbedingt mal vorbeischauen
sollte der link es ihr nein hier und
emmi unsere galaxis die milchstraße ist
durchzogen vom interstellaren medium
eine mischung aus staub gas und
kosmischer strahlung und an einigen
stellen verdichtet sich das
interstellare medium zu gut sichtbaren
molekülwolken und unser sonnensystem
befindet sich in so einer art aussparung
des interstellaren mediums die
sogenannte lokale blase sie wurde erst
vor wenigen jahrzehnten entdeckt durch
eine kombination aus optischer röntgen
und radioastronomie und nach und nach
fand man heraus dass sie eine riesige
region darstellt die etwa zehnmal
weniger dicht ist als das
durchschnittliche interstellare medium
in der milchstraße eine riesige hülle in
der unser sonnensystem drin ist da
werden jetzt einige von euch sagen das
erinnert mich an die heliosphäre sehr
guter einwand wo ist der unterschied
zwischen lokaler blase und heliosphäre
die heliosphäre es ebenfalls eine hülle
um unser sonnensystem herum aber sie ist
viel viel kleiner
so klein dass sogar schon von menschen
gebaute objekte sie verlassen haben
nämlich die voyager sonden die jenseits
der heliosphäre durch den interstellaren
raum düsen innerhalb der heliosphäre
verdrängt der sonnenwind also ein
partikelstrom der von der sonne
ausgestoßen wird das interstellare
medium nahezu komplett man könnte es
also so formulieren die lokale blase ist
eine enklave innerhalb des
interstellaren mediums und die
heliosphäre sein enklave innerhalb der
lokalen blase in der lokalen blase ist
das interstellare medium weniger dicht
in der heliosphäre ist es vollständig
verdrängt die lokale blase war aber
bislang immer sehr rätselhaft und man
hatte keine genaue vorstellung von ihrem
aussehen oder ihrer entstehung ein
forschungsteam des harvard smithsonian
center for astrophysics ist es aber nun
gelungen die blase so genau zu
kartografieren wie nie zuvor und sie
fanden heraus dass unsere lokale blase
eng verbunden ist mit den heftigen
explosionen von riesigen sternen aber
immer der reihe nach es ist gar nicht so
einfach über eine struktur etwas
herauszufinden in der man drin ist
stellt man vor ihr wollt etwas über die
ausmaße eines hauses herausfinden könnte
aber die küche nicht verlassen es macht
die ganze sache so ein bisschen
kompliziert um dennoch etwas über die
lokale blase herauszufinden nutzte das
forschungsteam daten des
weltraumteleskops dieses weltraum
teleskop dient der kartierung der
position und bewegungen von sternen
innerhalb der milchstraße mit der
bislang mit abstand höchste präzision
sie erstellten anhand der geier daten
eine karte des gases und der jungen
sterne im umkreis von etwa 650
lichtjahren um unser sonnensystem herum
das brachte schon mal eine interessante
erkenntnis sie fanden heraus dass sich
alle jungen sterne also sterne die er so
ein paar hundert millionen jahre alt
sind was für sterne noch recht jung und
knackig ist und alle
sternentstehungsgebiete an der
oberfläche der lokalen blase befinden
die erklärung dafür ist spektakulär
innerhalb unserer blase muss es einst
jede menge supernova explosionen gegeben
haben wenn sich eine supernova nach
außen aus den komplett mit sie das
material in das sie expandiert und
schiebt und verdichtet es immer weiter
nach außen dadurch entstehende dichte
ansammlungen von molekularem gas am
rande des ausdehnungsgefäß den
interstellaren medium schweben und dann
unter ihrer eigenen schwerkraft
zusammenbrechen wenn dichte gasnebel
kollabieren dann entstehen neue baby
stern und die supernova explosion wurde
das interstellare medium in bestimmten
bereichen zusammengequetscht wodurch
eine riesiger leerraum entstanden ist
unsere lokale blase stellt euch mal vor
ihr würdet innerhalb einer
gesteinsschicht eine bombe zünden was
man halt so macht wenn man langeweile
hat dann entsteht innerhalb des gesteins
ein hohlraum und da mal land wird das
gestein zu einer dichteren schicht
zusammengepackt das ist genau der
prozess bestehen unsere lokale blase
entstanden ist das forschungsteam konnte
anhand der gaia daten aber noch viel
mehr details über die entstehung der
lokalen blase zurückrechnen sie fanden
heraus dass die geschichte der blase vor
etwa 14,4 millionen jahren begann
zunächst in einer periode der
sternentstehung gefolgt von den
supernovae massereicher kurzlebiger
stern 14,4 millionen jahre ist im
kosmischen maßstab gar nichts quasi nur
ein augenblick unsere galaxis ist wohl
schon über zehn milliarden jahre alt das
team hat errechnet dass die blase durch
ungefähr 15 supernovae über diesen
zeitraum von 14,4 millionen jahren
entstanden ist und die blase dehnt sich
immer noch nach außen aus mit einer
geschwindigkeit von etwa 6,7 kilometer
pro sekunde während man gut in mathe
nicht wie ich dann könnte man jetzt
ausrechnen wie viel die lokale blase
gewachsen ist seit dieses video begonnen
hat wenn ihr gut rechnen können dann
schreibt uns die antwort gerne meinen
die kommentare bleibt noch eine große
frage warum ist unser sonnensystem
ausgerechnet in zentrum der blase
antwort das ist reiner zufall so seltsam
das auch klingt zu erklären ist dass mit
der bewegung unseres sonnensystems durch
die galaxie unser sonnensystem rast um
das zentrum der milchstraße mit models
gut festhalten einer geschwindigkeit von
900 tausend kilometern pro stunde da
kann einem schon mal schwindlig werden
wir benötigen 225 millionen jahre einmal
um das zentrum der milchstraße herum das
bezeichnet man als ein galaktisches jahr
am anfang dieses galaktischen jahres
begann also gerade mal das zeitalter der
dinosaurier und durch diese bewegung ist
unser sonnensystem in die lokale blase
hineingeschlittert der physiker und
astronom joao alves von der universität
wien beschreibt es so als die ersten
supernovae lokal blase erzeugten
austragen war unsere sonne weit vom
geschehen aber vor etwa fünf millionen
jahren führte der weg der sonne durch
die galaxie genau die blase und jetzt
sitzt die sonne nur durch zufall fast
geheult zentrum der blase ziemlich
komischer zufall dass ausgerechnet unser
sonnensystem in das zentrum der blase
hinein gewandert ist oder irgendwie ja
außer die milchstraße wäre voll mit
solchen blasen und genau das ist das
ergebnis das das forschungsteam aus der
studie zieht sie sagen dass unsere
galaxis so ein bisschen wie so ein
schweizer käse aufgebaut ist überall in
der galaxis befinden sich riesige löcher
riesige blasen im interstellaren medium
eben überall dort wo es zu vielen
supernova explosionen kommt und das
interstellare medium verdrängt wird und
unsere lokale blase es eben nur eine
davon wenn man sich die milchstraße also
komplett mit blasen durchlöchert
vorstellt dann erscheint ist plötzlich
gar nicht mehr so unwahrscheinlich dass
unser sonnensystem auf seiner
galaktischen wanderung eben in das
zentrum einer solchen blase
hineingetrieben wird vielleicht wird es
in einigen millionen jahren auch wieder
diese blase verlassen und irgendwann
eine neue erreichen und natürlich
könnten durch weitere
supernova-explosionen irgendwann auch
galaktische blasen vernichtet werden und
anderenorts neu entstehen ihr seht die
milchstraße ist nicht statisch in ihrem
aufbau sondern befindet sich immer noch
in andauernder veränderung die lokale
blase ist aber nicht die einzige
struktur in unserer galaktischen
nachbarschaft forschende haben zwischen
unserem sonnensystem und dem zentrum der
galaxis eine mysteriöse kosmische wand
entdeckt die auch etwas mit dem
schwarzen loch im zentrum der
milchstraße zu tun hat was könnte es
damit auf sich habe tim hat euch dazu
auf seinem kanal alles wichtige
berichtet klickt man auf das angezeigte
video also jetzt nicht kommt dann kommt
es gleich um es euch anzuschauen dem hat
mehr außerdem erzählt das ist sein
großes ziel ist in den nächsten wochen
die 100.000 abusir bei youtube zu
knacken wir können ihm doch ein bisschen
dabei helfen also hier anklicken da
anschauen und hirt ems kanal abonnieren
ich verlasse mich auf euch wir sehen uns
im nächsten video ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran